hey Steven Spielberg it's me Academy  award-winning actor Nick Cage and I want  to audition for Lincoln  slavery man that is not cool for store  and seven years ago man our forefathers  brought forth freaking America my fellow  Americans I have invented the $5 bail  Yahoo can I keep this I just invested in  a miniature horse farm Joey stop this  bleeding seriously  the walls are bleeding don't you see it  how do we stop that oh [ __ ] not the bees  know not the bees ah you know I could  also play Mary Todd babe honey don't go  to the theater tonight you know I have a  premonition  I see snakes possum blood and they're  just I'm really horny - hey b c d e f g  h i j k l m n o p q r s 2 u 3 tell me  that's why z huh oh man I've been shot  in the head suck it will hey steve-o  thanks for watching make it really use  the work I have a couple late payments  on my island